kyler murray one of the big stories of
the day yesterday a couple of stories
kareem hunt calamari we're going to
start with kyler murray kyler murray is
now fully committed to playing football
so he says for now so someone says for
now and i'm going to be cynical here i
like colimer and i wish him the best but
i'm not doing my job if i don't take a
hard look at the things that are being
said and done to try to get to the
bottom of what's really happening and
i've been skeptical for a while now that
murray is going to try to play both
sides of this he's going to try to keep
a foot in each boat
as he pro progresses through february
march and april and makes a final
decision about whether to play football
after he sees who drafts him and how
high he's drafted but in order to get
drafted as high as possible you can't
say that you have to go all in with
football the statement that was posted
yesterday on his twitter page may or may
not have been written by him the a's
reportedly believe it was written by his
new agent eric burkhart the statement
reads as follows moving forward i am
firmly and fully committing my life and
time to becoming an nfl quarterback
football has been my love and passion my
entire life i was raised to play
quarterback and i very much look forward
to dedicating 100 of myself to being the
best possible quarterback and winning
nfl championships i have started an
extensive training program to further
prepare myself for upcoming nfl workouts
and interviews i eagerly await the
opportunity to continue to prove to nfl
decision makers that i am the franchise
quarterback in this draft okay
here's the thing
if he was raised to play quarterback if
football has been his love and passion
his entire life why did he take money
from the oakland a's last year when they
drafted them plenty of guys get drafted
they don't take the money from the team
why did he do it
why
that's the first question i'm asking in
indianapolis in two weeks at the
scouting combine
these interviews
for kyler murray
when you consider the circumstances when
you consider the fact that he did take
the money from the a's when you consider
the fact that the a's are still there
and i think the a's are playing this
beautifully we wrote about this last
night ken rosenthal of the athletic has
taken the view that the a's are still in
this the a's are ready to go the a's
aren't constrained by the same
limitations that will prevent what an
nfl team can pay
kyler murray that the a's can offer more
whatever the team that drafts kyle or
murray is able to pay under the cba the
a's can pay more and the a's seem to be
determined to still try to get kyler
murray now whether or not they really
are determined
and let's just take them at their word
that they are determined that throws a
hell of a wrench into the gears for kyle
murray because no matter what he says no
matter what he does
that pathway remains
back to baseball it's there he can go
back to baseball whenever he wants
because the a's are making it clear hey
we're fine well no we're not upset we
could be upset we could tell this kid i
forget it we're done with you we're not
playing this game we're not going to be
your leverage against the nfl we're
going to move on to someone else but
they're not
they are determined to still sign kyler
murray which is going to complicate
murray's life over the next two and a
half months because he's going to be
asked over and over and over again and
this time around when he is in these
15-minute meetings at the scouting
combine and when he's otherwise meeting
with teams he's not going to have
handlers there he's not going to have
agents here his dad's not going to be
there that awkward interview that he had
with dan patrick super bowl week
dan at one point said dad can can he
answer the question dad's a little
involved dad's not going to be involved
at the scouting combine kyle is going to
have to go in and he's going to have to
answer these questions and the teams are
going to be looking for reasons not to
take him especially because you're going
to have scouts in pretty much every team
that is arguing against kylie murray
because of his size not just his height
but his size we had russell wilson and
kyla murray at the set that we had at
radio row in atlanta just a couple of
hours apart and i i was struck
by how much smaller kyle murray is than
russell wilson they're both short but
wilson
wilson has that nfl quarterback
thickness to him where you can look at
him and say this guy can walk out there
between the white lines and protect
himself
murray
he just he looks little i'd be nervous
i'd be scared are you sure you're all
right out there kyler do you know what
you're doing these are really big strong
guys are you sure you can handle
yourself out there because you're not
really all that big and i don't know
that his frame allows him to pack on all
that much muscle i mean seven years ago
russell wilson wasn't built like he is
now i just don't know that murray's
frame is going to allow it there's a
picture floating around and i need to
post this at the website at some point
of murray standing with dwayne haskins
and tonga or tuatanga viloa of alabama
at the heisman
ceremonies
i i
it's it's it's jaw dropping how much
smaller murray is especially than
haskins and now haskins and murray are
the two quarterbacks in the draft pool
the two two of the names we're going to
hear the most about going into late
april so
and these are issues that he is not
going to be able to get away from and
he's going to be facing tough questions
tough scrutiny about
his size his stature and whether or not
he truly is committed to playing
football because look
whether whether he believes it at this
point or not
if he ends up going lower than he thinks
he should go and he said it himself in
this statement
he wants to prove that i am the
franchise quarterback in this draft
right so if he's the third quarterback
taken the second quarterback taken
anything other than the first name off
the board does that change his view on
the nfl well these teams have gotten it
wrong they're not properly assessing my
skills so i'm gonna maybe have second
thoughts about playing football maybe
i'll play baseball instead and if you've
got the a's there throwing more money on
the pile
yeah it's a heck of a risk there's a
risk that you're going to be the tampa
bay buccaneers in 1986 drafting bo
jackson first overall and he never plays
for you
because see football teams only hold
rights for one year
after a year kyle murray goes back into
the draft poll assuming someone drafts
him if no one drafts him then he's a
free agent able to sign with anyone at
any time
but
if he's drafted those rights last for
one year and then he goes back into the
draft pool next year remember 1986 1987
86 it was the bucks in round one
bo jackson didn't play football 87
the raiders took a seventh round flyer
at a time when there were 12 rounds in
the draft and bo jackson said yeah i'll
play football part-time and and i really
do think
that kyler murray's preference would be
if he could find a way to pull it off
and i think he's going to try to do it
although i don't think he is going to
get anywhere with it he'd like to play
both
he said that to us
he'd really like to play both he knows
it's highly highly highly highly
unlikely but he didn't say it's
impossible
i don't know that he can pull it off he
probably can't but if he's even holding
out hope of playing both then there is a
chance that this full commitment to
football isn't as full as he would say
and look we have to be cynical we have
to be skeptical we have to understand
that this this is part of the game it's
no different than running 40 yards in a
straight line or how high you can jump
or all the things you do at the scouting
combine there's a certain ritual to this
the things you do the things you say to
get drafted as high as possible the goal
between now and the end of april is to
get drafted as high as possible then
after you get drafted wherever you're
drafted you figure out what you're going
to do
just because you've been drafted doesn't
mean that you are legally committed to
playing for that team
the giants reportedly are out on
kyler murray they believe he's too small
i guess a team called the giants would
be
you know the most likely to have
concerns about size but look at that
look at this
look
there's another angle where it's even
more jaw dropping
but the difference between look at the
difference between haskins and murr they
play the same position
and haskins
has been spectacular
if i'm dwayne haskins i'm getting upset
by all this kyler murray talk hey people
you forget about me
passer and a runner not just a runner
some some would say just a runner no no
no no dwayne haskins pastor ander
and uh
look these size concerns are going to be
an issue maybe maybe maybe murray's
genius here is he's making the issue his
commitment to football and not his size
but here's reality it's going to be both
and you're going to have voices
in these organizations saying between
the risk that he's going to go play
baseball versus the reality that he
isn't as big as he should be it's not
worth it let's draft a guy that we know
is going to show up see murray is the
worst nightmare for an nfl team when
it's time to make a draft pick because
unlike every other guy that they may
draft murray has a very viable and
realistic option to play another
professional sport and make as much or
possibly more money
most guys
they don't have that
and the fact that you don't get that
commitment at the time you draft the guy
that you then have to sign him to a
contract that could be the thing that
scares
some teams away and we'll have plenty of
time to talk about
which teams may be seriously interested
in kyler murray and this whole draft
process he'll have the pro day workout
he'll have the scouting combine but that
those three days are already stressful
enough for the guys who go to
indianapolis with all the poking and the
prodding and the dehumanizing treatment
it's going to be even worse for kyle
murray because i think that anyone who
was paying attention to the dan patrick
interview from a couple of weeks ago
that they're going to be ready to
to really push this guy to see if he has
what it takes to be an nfl quarterback
from the standpoint of answering
questions in a confident manner carrying
himself a certain way
making it clear that he really is all in
with football that he can be trusted in
that regard and
uh
that he's not going to eventually have a
change of heart and oh by the way one
last point i mentioned that eric
burkhart is reportedly his agent
burkhardt also represents
cardinals coach cliff kingsbury who has
said that that and this was months ago
that if he had the first pick in the nfl
draft he would take kyler murray so that
isn't going away anytime soon even
though the cardinals have josh rosen
under contract they could end up having
rosen under contract and kyler murray's
draft rights and i do have a feeling
that if kyle murray were the first
overall pick in the draft he's probably
going to go ahead and sign an nfl
contract the question is how many picks
after number one
will it take for him to start thinking
maybe i need to change my mind about my
100 commitment to football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports